good afternoon everyone i'm assistant
sheriff chris jones
and i'm here to brief you on additional
details as we know them today
reference the officer-involved shooting
that occurred on tuesday october 27
2020. the officers that were involved in
this ois are assigned to the
investigative services division
gain crimes bureau they work in
plainclothes capacity
and as such they do not wear body-worn
cameras
the officers uh were wearing tactical
vests with insignias that clearly
identified them as police
and we do have body worn camera from the
patrol officers who were on scene
we also have um surveillance camera from
inside
the convenience store we'll show those
after my remarks
this is ois number 17 for this year
it is fatal it is fatal number nine at
this time last year we had 14 oises
and 10 of those
were fatal
this event began as a shooting near the
area of desert inn and maryland parkway
on october 27th at approximately 10 30
a.m
an individual identified as maurice
parker
was identified as a suspect in that
shooting
and that was based on witness statements
surveillance video
as well as casings from that scene were
matched with the firearm that mr parker
had on him
when he was contacted by officers those
casings were linked forensically
through our niben system
the officer-involved shooting occurred
in the 2500 block of north pecos road
las vegas nevada 89115
and that's in northeast area command you
can see the map
to my left
the officers involved are sergeant
stephen perry
sergeant perry is 52 years old he's been
with lvmpd since 1999.
in this incident sergeant perry was
armed with a glock 17
nine millimeter equipped with a tactical
light
the investigation revealed that sergeant
perry fired one round
second officer involved is detective
eric stafford
s-t-a-f-f-o-r-d
detective stafford is 35 years old he's
been with las vegas metro since 2008
in this incident detective stafford was
armed with the remington 870
12-gauge shotgun it was equipped with a
tactical light
and the investigation revealed that
detective stafford fired one round
the third detective involved is
detective julian pappas
p-a-p-p-a-s detective pappas is 31 years
old and he's been with las vegas metro
since 2014. in this incident detective
pappas was armed the glock 19
nine millimeter the investigation
refilled revealed that he fired eight
rounds
lastly is detective salon mcgill
s-o-l-o-n mcgill m-c-g-i-l-l
detective mcgill is 41 years old and
he's been with las vegas metro since
2013.
in this incident detective mcgill was
armed with a wilson combat
1911 45 caliber handgun
investigation revealed that he fired
three rounds during this incident
the suspect was identified as maurice
parker
mr parker's 34 years of age he's a black
male
6-1 235 pounds he's pictured to my left
as i mentioned before he was also the
suspect who has identified
in the shooting that occurred earlier
that morning
mr parker was armed with a taurus g2c
40 caliber handgun it was loaded with 10
rounds in the magazine
mr parker's charges had he survived
would have been shooting into an
occupied structure
conspiracy to discharge a gun within a
vehicle
or prohibited area prohibited person
in possession of a firearm resisting an
officer with a deadly weapon
an assault with a deadly weapon on a
public officer
details of this ois on tuesday october
27
2020 at approximately 10 30 a.m
a shooting occurred in the 3300 block of
brussels
b-r-u-s-s-e-l-s
street and that's near d.i desert inn
and maryland parkway
it was reported that several shots were
fired into a vehicle
by a male who was later identified as
maurice parker
fortunately no one was injured in this
event
at approximately 8 25 pm that same day
gang detectives were conducting a
follow-up and investigating the shooting
detectives learned that mr parker was
employed as a clerk
at a convenience store located in in the
2500 block
of north pecos sergeant perry
along with detectives pappas mcgill and
stafford
drove to the store to arrest mr parker
for the shooting
as detectives approached the store they
immediate immediately start
spotted mr parker standing behind the
cash register
sergeant perry the rest of the
detectives and two patrol officers made
entry into the store
and gave mr parker verbal commands to
keep his hands in the air
on the back of his head and to not move
mr parker initially complied and placed
his hands on his head
and faced away from the officers as he
was instructed
as sergeant perry continued to issue
issue verbal commands
mr parker reached into his waistband and
produced a handgun
and turn toward the officers and we'll
show you video of that shortly
simultaneously sergeant perry detective
pappas
detective mcgill and detective stafford
fired their weapons
striking mr parker
officers immediately summoned medical
personnel but mr parker succumbed to his
injuries at the scene
this time i'll show you both body worn
camera footage
and then we'll show you surveillance
footage from the convenience store
of the shooting
you'll see that they make contact with
him
he initially complies
and then he'll quickly reach into his
waistband lifting his shirt
to pull out his firearm as he turns
towards the officers
this is a slowed down version of that
fisheye
camera
that's the firearm that he was reaching
for
here's another perspective from the
body-worn camera
do not move put your hands on top of
your head
turn around slowly do not move do not go
on your knees
stand up straight do not move
interlock your fingers stand up straight
foreign
[Music]
you can see in that slowed down version
as he starts to lift his shirt
and reach into his waistband for that
firearm
that was later recovered nearby inside
the store and that's the firearm that
was in the holster
i'll take any questions
violence or irregular violence or
something like that
yes he has firearms charges that are out
of
california utah and other charges are
out in nevada
in addition to that he was on a federal
supervision for
prohibited person in possession of a
firearm and that chewing
the first that happened i believe that
during the morning happened very close
to that
location no that's in a different area
of town
the shooting is in the 2500 block of
north pecos
um so pecos north of lake mead and that
shooting occurred
earlier in the day near desert inn and
maryland
you have like any parkway for that
we believe that it was narcotics related
and the witnesses were the ones that
actually
told you that he was a clerk and that's
why you were able to find it so quick
so those witnesses in that shooting were
not aware that he was a clerk no we
learned that he was a clerk later on
through the investigation
officers are on paid administrative
leave as is routine
while the investigation continues
all right thank you very much